>>> NOW ON USA, "MR. ROBOT," THE
AWARD-WINNING TECHNO-THRILLING
SERIES ABOUT THE PARANOID MIND
OF THE WORLD'S GREATEST HACKER.
>> HELLO, FRIEND.
>> HE'S ALREADY HACKED THE WORLD
ECONOMY.
BUT NOW HE FACES HIS GREATEST
CHALLENGE YET.
>> HEY, MAN.
YOU KNOW COMPUTERS?
>> YEAH.
WHO ARE YOU?
>> OH, WELL, THAT HURT.
LESSEE JONES, "SNL"?
YOU GOT TO HELP ME FIND OUT WHO
HACKED MY PICS, WHO GOT ALL MY
LITTLE NASTIES.
>> UH --
>> THE VICTIM OF THE
SUMMER'S BIGGEST HACK TURNS THE
TABLES WITH THE HELP OF TV'S
MOST NOTORIOUS HACKER.
>> GOT MY LAPTOP RIGHT HERE IN
MY BAG.
YOU DO KNOW WINDOWS 95, RIGHT?
>> OF COURSE, MAN.
>> GOT THE CORD.
PLUG THAT BAD BY IN AND LET IT
WARM UP FOR HOURS.
>> IT'S A PUZZLE UNLIKE ANY HE'S
FACED BEFORE.
>> YO, DUDE, HOW YOU DOING OVER
THERE?
>> STILL TRYING TO GET THE LAY
OF THE LAND.
SO MANY DELTA BOARDING PASSES.
>> IT'S A JOB FOR THE WHOLE "F"
SOCIETY TEAM.
>> WHAT THE HELL, ELLIOT, WHO IS
SHE?
THIS IS NOT SAFE.
WHY ARE YOU HELPING HER?
>> YO, BITCH, I DO NOT NEED THIS
RIGHT NOW, FOR REAL, CHILL.
>> A DIVE INTO THE BROKEN MIND
OF AN UNSTABLE GENIUS AND THE
HACKER SHE HIRED TO HELP.
>> COME ON, PUT MY PASSWORD IN,
P-A-S -- HEY, YOU GOT IT, DUDE!
>> IT WAS "PASSWORD."
>> DAMN, YOU IS GOOD, DUDE.
>> BUT YOU COULD BE GREAT IF YOU
DIDN'T LET YOUR EMOTIONS GET THE
BEST OF YOU.
>> OH, WELL HELLO THERE.
>> YOU CAN SEE MR. ROBOT?
>> SO IS THERE A MRS. ROBOT?
>> NO, HE'S A GHOST, HE'S DEAD.
>> I AIN'T AFRAID OF NO GHOST.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> AND THE STARTLING CONCLUSION
YOU WON'T BELIEVE.
>> LESLIE, I FOUND YOUR HACKER.
>> WHO THIS IS BITCH?
OH, THAT'S ME.
>> IT SEEMED YOU HACKED YOUR
PHOTOS TO YOUR ONLIGHT WEBSITE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU DID IT,
IT'S REALLY HARD TO DO.
>> WELL, I GOT A PHOTO SHOOT
WITH "AMTRAK MAGAZINE" SO THANKS
FOR THIS.
>> I SHOULD PROBABLY FEEL
SOMETHING RIGHT NOW BUT I DON'T.
>> HOLD ON, HOLD ON, MAN.
THIS JUST DON'T FEEL BALANCED.
GOOD GOD.
ALL RIGHT.
GET SOME VITAMINS, MAN.
GET SOME SLEEP.
Y'ALL MILLENNIALS DON'T TAKE
CARE OF YOURSELF.
>> BE BA BOO BOO BE BA BOO MR.
ROBOT.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]